ce dont j'avais envie de
parler aujourd'hui c'est effectivement à
quoi sert la justice pénale
internationale et la première
se poser c'est le monde aujourd'hui est
il moins violent est-ce qu'on est plus
ou moins barbare nous les humains moi je
travaille sur les crimes de guerre la
justice pénale internationale la guerre
dont nous a parlé emeric et la réalité
de cette guerre c'est les combattons
effectivement moi je suis du côté des
victimes
j'ouvre des charniers je poursuis des
enquêtes et j'accompagne ses victimes
pour obtenir un peu de justice
alors qu'est ce qu'un criminel de guerre
c'est aussi une question qu'on peut se
poser
moi je me la pose beaucoup est ce que
chacun d'entre nous n'importe qui peut
basculer pouvons tous devenir des
bourreaux
cette question elle se pose pour chacun
on vit dans un monde aujourd'hui où il y
a énormément de conflit partout on nous
parle de dèche
on nous parle de boko haram où je
reviens du sahel le soudan l'afghanistan
la république démocratique du congo le
burundi aujourd'hui tous ces pays je les
ai fait je continue de les faire
pourtant j'ai une bonne nouvelle le
monde va mieux si vous l'avez pas encore
fait je vous engage à regarder les
statistiques fait par l'excellent en
scrolling médecin statisticiens qui nous
montre que les revenus par habitant
depuis 120 ans progresse et que on vit
plus longtemps et que les guerres les
plus terribles comme la première et la
seconde guerres mondiales n'ont pas
affecté ce progrès et le droit
international pénal
il y est pour quelque chose aussi au
moment de la seconde guerre mondiale
l'humanité a vécu la shoah est la
réponse qui a été donné en matière de
justice pénale internationale a été le
tribunal de nuremberg et en 1948 le
tribunal de nuremberg est montée et on
commence à poser des mots sur des faits
et pour moi la justice pénale
internationale c'est d'abord ça et puis
ce prémisse qui va rester un peu lente
pendant plusieurs années ce sont les
débuts d'une marche d'une marche
entreprises par cette justice pénale
internationale
silencieuse lente et les années 90 nous
amène avec le conflit en bosnie au
rwanda à la décision de créer deux
tribunaux adopte le tribunal pénal
international de la haye pour lequel
j'ai travaillé donc j'ai commencé ma
carrière et le tribunal pénal
international pour le rwanda des
tribunaux hybrides aussi dont on parle
beaucoup moins existe en sierra leone au
cambodge pour le liban et puis le
j'allais dire le succès là de cette
justice pénale internationale c'est
cette fameuse cour pénale internationale
qui est permanente aujourd'hui et qui
est là pour juger les crimes contre
l'humanité les génocides les crimes de
guerre un crime contre l'humanité qu'est
ce que c'est un crime contre notre
propre humanité
mais cette justice pénale internationale
on peut effectivement se demander à quoi
elle sert
est-ce que bachar el-assad aujourd'hui
il est préoccupé par la cour pénale
internationale pat romain est ce que
bachir président du soudan mais
préoccupé par la cour pénale
internationale qui l'a mis en accusation
depuis dix ans pas vraiment alors
on peut se dire bon très bien ces
institutions elles sont là ça sert à
quoi
la deuxième question c'est est-ce que
cette justice pénale internationale sert
les victimes est ce qu'elles apportent
quelque chose là encore elle apporte
beaucoup d'espoir elle a fonctionné pour
le tribunal pour l'ex yougoslavie
mais là il ya une semaine les victimes
parce que la cour pénale donc donne une
possibilité pour les victimes de se
porter partie civile
je travaille aussi sur ces questions et
les victimes du soudan qui s'étaient
portées partie civile devant la cour
pénale internationale ont décidé de
retirer leur plainte
au bout de dix ans pourquoi parce qu'
elle ne voit rien venir parce que le
président bachir se promène partout dans
le monde sans aucun problème la cour
pénale internationale n'a pas de pouvoir
de coercition justice pénale
internationale n'a pas de bras armé
aymeric nous a parlé nous a montré
kadhafi j'ai travaillé en libye saïf al
islam le fils de kadhafi est en libye
mis en accusation par la cour pénale
internationale
oui il n'est pas à l'oeil alors moi je
me suis posé des questions aussi est ce
que la justice pénale internationale ça
n'est que ces juridictions pénales
internationales
est ce que ce ne sont que ces tribunaux
cette cour pénale dont tout le monde
parlait au final pas tellement grand
monde comprend comment elle fonctionne
ben non
la justice pénale internationale c'est
nous c'est vous c'est tout le monde
la plupart des états du monde définissez
qualifier les crimes de guerre les
génocides la torture beaucoup de pays du
monde aussi entreprennent dans leur pays
des actions en justice
parfois avec une certaine volonté
politique mais la plupart du temps
surtout parce que ce sont les victimes
qui s'acharne et qui se battent pour ça
et c'est auprès d'elle que je fais ce
travail et tout ce travail là il est
possible et pour moi la justice pénale
internationale
c'est ça en 2009 en bosnie j'ai créé une
unité de crimes de guerre avec les
procureurs et les policiers locaux
j'ai conduit le premier procès de viol
pour crimes de guerre en libye j'ai
accompagné le ministre de la justice
marc ganis et on a fait adopter par
décret une loi qui reconnaît les viols
massifs qui ont lieu en libye et met en
place une commission en bosnie j'ai fait
adopter dès décret de loi qui amène
réparation aux victimes en croatie il ya
quelques semaines le modèle de cette loi
a été adoptée encore une fois sur les
viols qui sont des crimes de guerre elle
dont je vous parlerai un tout petit peu
plus tard donc cette justice pénale
internationale
peut-être que il faudrait qu'on arrête
de la regarder comme ça en eau
cette cour pénale dont on attend tous
est en fait l'impossible aujourd'hui on
a pas mal parlé dans certains toque de
la technologie on vit dans un monde
globalisé
on peut effectivement s'informer on peut
tous agir exprimer nos opinions
on peut disrupt et le système
seulement moi dans mon domaine un mois
les institutions internationales où tout
est lisse disrupt et le système c'est
super plus difficile que tous ces
entrepreneurs et cet art stop start up
pardon croyez moi et pourtant moi je
continue ce travail parce que je crois
que la justice du futur c'est justement
de district et système comand d'abord en
arrêtant de regarder les victimes comme
des victimes
les victimes la plupart du temps elles
ont vécu des choses horribles mais ce
sont des gens d'une dignité qu'ils sont
capables de conduire des combats
acharnés pendant des années juste pour
qu'on leur reconnaisse un tout petit peu
de justice juste pour qu'on la
reconnaisse leur existence ouvrir un
charnier retrouver quelqu'un pouvoir
l'enterrer
ça redonne cette dignité à ces victimes
je reviens du tchad effectivement et
vous l'avez certainement vu en ce moment
à dakar il ya le procès en cours
d'hissène habré ancien président du
tchad
et si ce procès a lieu aujourd'hui c'est
grâce aux victimes qui se sont battus
pour qu'il ait lieu
c'est grâce à la pression publique en
france on a eu des condamnations sur le
rwanda
il ya quelque chose qui s'appelle la
compétence universelle qui existe depuis
très longtemps que les états peuvent
mettre en place la france le faire avec
des conditions malheureusement un peu
particulière dont celle de résidence
aller sur le terrain
c'est allé regarder les conflits d'une
autre façon aymeric le fait du point de
vue des combattants et de la guerre est
là où je le rejoins c'est que la réalité
de la guerre elle est pas à blanche ou
grise la réalité de la guerre elle a la
couleur des ciels gris divers la guerre
c'est les combattants c'est ces images
qu'on a vu mais ce sont des victimes et
des histoires de personnes
aujourd'hui quand vous allumez votre
télévision votre téléphone votre ipad
tout ce que vous voulez on vous parle de
crime en masse on vous parle de chiffres
mais chaque chiffre c'est vous et c'est
moi c'est des histoires de personnes
comme vous et comme moi qui ont une
histoire qui sont médecins chirurgiens
calme le bleu le rouge
ce sont des gens est cette justice
pénale internationale
elle fonctionnera que si elle est portée
par ces gens là comme elle l'est
aujourd'hui chacun d'entre vous vous
pouvez aussi y participer en vous
informant en vous engageant moi comme je
voulais dit je suis juriste
l'impossibilité pour moi ça a pas
vraiment de sens
je suis déterminé parfois ça fonctionne
parfois ça fonctionne pas quand on va
travailler dans le sud kivu j'étais en
début octobre début octobre pardon ou au
tchad où ça a été extrêmement difficile
on a un peu désespérée mais il ya plein
d'autres endroits où ça marche
et puis le temps fait qu'on avance
la preuve on à la cour pénale
internationale aujourd'hui il ya
cinquante ans on n'avait rien et puis
rappelez vous le monde va mur
alors je continue ce travail sur le
terrain il fit l'année dernière j'ai
créé une ong consacré à la violence
sexuelle dans les conflits parce qu une
des particularités qui a été oublié
c'est que le viol est un élément
constitutif de crimes de guerre et on
oublie souvent on en parle peu alors
j'ai décidé d'en faire un enjeu mondial
public dans quelques temps on va lancer
une campagne parce qu'on fonctionne sur
un système très collaboratif en amenant
les gens à s'engager
pas spécialement avec de l'argent pas
spécialement avec du temps mais avec
plein de choses en s'informant en
partageant en expliquant ce que c'est
que le viol de guerre chacun d'entre
vous vous pouvez décider le monde dans
lequel vous voulez vivre
je ne crois pas aujourd'hui en 2015 que
les institutions ou les politiques
peuvent décider de tout
il a dit quoi le think tank c'est vous
je crois que c'est profondément vrai le
think tank c'est vous et puis j'avais
envie de vous pas citer cette phrase qui
moi m'a toujours portés dans mon travail
de l'excellent écrivain mark twain qui
disait les deux jours les plus
importants de votre vie c'est celui où
vous êtes né quand vous êtes né et le
second c'est celui quand vous avez
compris pourquoi alors ce soir ce que
j'avais envie de vous dire plutôt que de
vous parler de charniers ou de deux
crimes de guerre c'est chercher votre
sens à vous trouvez votre pourquoi soyez
courageux
soyez bienveillant et soyez optimiste
merci